configuring the network settings for our
system has always been an hassle
but through the use of some of the
important network commands we can easily
configure and also troubleshoot network
settings for our device
hi guys and welcome to yet an advantage
video by simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
now let's look into the agenda for
today's video
to begin with we will understand what
exactly are network commands
moving on with what are some of the
important network commands
and in the end we will see the demo for
the network commands
let's begin
the first is what are network commands
the windows operating system provides
its user with numerous built-in network
troubleshooting commands these commands
allows its user to maintain the network
stability of the system
let's move on with network commands
now let's look into some of the most
important and mostly used network
commands in the windows prompt
the first one is ipconfig
this is one of the most basic network
commands used in the windows prompt it
gives an overview of the network
settings for our system
moving on we have ipconfig all
this is similar to ipconfig
but it gives a more detailed view of the
network settings for our system
then we have ping
this command is used to check
or test whether destination host is
available for exchange of services or
information moving on we have tracearty
this command provides the user with an
overview of the path that has been taken
by our iep address to reach the
destination ip host
then we have nslookup
this command is used when we have to
look into the server data of a
particular internet server for example
google.com
now let's look into some of the more
network commands
this we have
root
the root command provides the data of
routing data packets in the system over
the communication channel
netsat
it is used to get an overview of all the
currently connected networks from our
system
then we have arp the arp command is used
to display the arp cache in an organized
format
then we have path ping
using this command provides us with the
output combination that is of both trace
rt
and ping to a certain extent
and in the end we have system info
this command provides us with the
comprehensive overview of the device
settings in a system
now let's look into the demo for the
network commands to better understand
them
to execute the network commands we have
to access the windows prompt
to do this
type cmd
and you will
access your command prompt
the first network command that we will
execute is ipconfig
the ipconfig command displays
network settings as an output
as we can see
this is the main connection that my
system currently have
with the ip address
192.168.1.3
along with every ip address a subnet
mask is included this is very important
as already told ipconfig just shows an
overview of the connection settings but
if you want to look into more detailed
version of the network settings for our
system
we use the command
ipconfig
all
as visible ipconfig oil command provides
us with a much more detailed view of our
connection settings
including dhcp settings
along with the lease obtained for ip
address
the default gateway
including the dhcp server settings
also
details about the dns server
now let's take a look at the next
network command in the list that is
nslookup
ns lookup command is used to access the
ip address of a particular website or a
host through its domain name
this network command is helpful when we
don't know the ip address and wants to
know it
but we only have the domain name
let's take a look
let's clear the screen for much proper
view
ns lookup
by default the nth lookup command
provides us
with the data of our system
that is the default server that my
system is currently connected to
and the ip address of my system
to access some other website or host's
ip address through its domain name you
have to write
ww dot
in this case let's take google
dot com
and press enter
through this from this part we can
access the ip address that has been used
by google.com
let's try using some other domain name
for example
www.amazon.com
as we can see
the ip address
the alias and the name from the
amazon.com
till this point we have seen what is
ipconfig command ipconfig all command
and the ns lookup
now let's move on to the next command
that is ping command is used to check
whether our system
can access a particular website
let's take a look
to come out of the ns lookup command do
control c
now let's try
pink
to access the ping command we will use
the domain name
www.amazon.com
and press enter
after the execution of the ping command
we can see
that our system sent four packets
and
the destination ip also received four
packets that means the loss is zero
this means that the amazon website is
accessible from a system and there is no
loss of data in during the transmission
in case if we don't have a domain name
for a particular website we can also use
the ip address for example
ping
and followed by the ip address
in this case let's take the amazon again
the ip address is
23.33.245.99
and press enter
as we can see the system has again sent
four packets to the destination ip
address and the destination has received
four packets without any loss
now let's move on to the next network
command in the list
that is tracearty the tracert command
is used to trace
the path that has been taken by our ip
address to reach the destination ip
address
which is very helpful if we want to
troubleshoot the part that has been
taken
but before we use tracert we need a
destination source
let's try using
nslookup
and
use the facebook's ip address
let's exit the ns lookup command
using control c
and type
trace rt along with the ip address of
facebook.com that is
157.240.228.35
and press enter
on execution of the tracert command we
can see the number of routers or network
devices that our system's ip address has
to go through to access facebook.com
and we can see the number of hops that
are available are 13.
let's see the number of hops our system
has to take to access facebook
and seems like the number of hops it
takes to access facebook from our system
is
it
through the use of tracearty command we
can see
how many hops and what devices or router
our ip address has to go through access
a particular website
now let's move on to the next network
command
that is root command
root command is used to access and
manipulate the ip routing table of our
system
you can access this command using route
and print
and this
enter
as we can take a look
it provides us with the destination ip
address along with the net mask gateway
and interface
all these are necessary
for a network programmer to take a look
of any details that are regarded in the
target or the destination ip address
host
with this let's move on to the next
network command that is
netstat
this network command is used to access
the connections that are currently
available on a computer system
through the tcp and udp ports
to display the result let's write
netstat
and press enter
from this we can take a look the number
of connections that are currently
available
or
inactive
or in case
closed
to the netstat command
now let's move on to the next network
command that is
arp
let's clear our screen
and use arp
the arp network command is used to
access
the ip addresses for a device along with
their physical addresses
to use this we have to write arp
if you do this and press enter you'll
access the help mode for arp command
to access the output you have to write
arp hyphen a
in presenter
with this we can take a look at the ip
address along with the physical address
and also the type of ip addresses they
are for example the first one is
a dynamic ip address whereas the rest of
them
are static
now let's move on to the next network
command in the list
that is the pathping command this
network command
is used
to access the path that our ip address
take for the destination host along with
the calculation of loss of the data that
has been transmitted over the
communication channel
to do this
type path thing
along with the destination source that
is for
example facebook.com
and press enter
on doing this
we get the number of routers and the
path that has been taken
by our ip address
to the destination host
partnering command might take some time
to execute
after the execution of the command this
is the whole result that we receive on
our
window these eight represents the path
and the statistic represent the loss
at each point of ip address during its
transmission over the channel
now let's take a look at the last
network command in our list that is
system info
after we suggest system info is used to
access or display
the whole overview of a system devices
setting
to do this write
system info
and press enter
as we can see
all the data regarding
my system device is
displayed
as an output
with this we have reached the end of the
video
if you have any questions regarding any
of the network commands you can ask them
in the comment section below
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here